former uh colleague of mine uh in the
nfl
and uh does a heck of a job um
uh broadcasting and as an analyst uh
chris chris sims joins us to talk about
tonight's trip welcome to the show chris
how you doing bud
what's up ryan how you doing man good to
talk to you everything good yeah
everything's great
uh i mean i don't think i've been more
interested in the draft simply because
of the mysteriousness of it all
and right um you know we're talking
about mostly we know what one and two
are going to look like because it's been
like that for a while but san francisco
threw a huge
curve in all of this about a month ago
moving up to three
having to know who they loved who they
moved up to get you feel pretty adamant
about where you are on this
who do they draft tonight yeah i do i
feel pretty adamant about it i mean
again i don't know i know everybody
thinks i know because i'm friends with
kyle shanahan and it's like
no he doesn't tell me everything i mean
i have one of the biggest mouths in the
world and i talk
every day on tv but i do know him
and i do know what he likes in
quarterbacks and that's where
i guess i would be shocked that it's not
matt jones
you know i i matt jones
is a matt ryan drew brees type of
quarterback and i think he's better than
them coming out
and i know shanahan has always had an
affinity for those type of guys
and i also know he he thinks that if he
got more than two years with matt ryan
he would have won a super bowl
and he was up 28 to 3 in one of them and
i know a lot of people blame him but
like the defense is allowed to stop
brady and the patriot
and all that so uh i i do i just
expect it to be mac jones like i said i
don't know
i'd be intrigued to see what a trey
lance would be like in the shanahan
offense it would be a little bit of that
rg3
washington combination that we saw you
know a few years back
but i think ultimately it's always been
about mac jones and and i will be like
fall
on the floor shocked if it's not him at
three tonight well you've been
you've been awfully good the last few
years and what i what i enjoy so much
about you is that
you know you you take a look at what you
like
uh you go about what the need is and and
and you you don't move off that spot
right it's your spot you you feel like
you have a pretty good idea where you're
going with that i remember the lamar
jackson
uh draft and how really excited you were
about them and when you went on the dan
patrick crow people kind of looked at
you like you were crazy but
uh he's he's an mvp in this league
because of what he's been able to
accomplish and so
uh i take it with a lot of heart the
biggest thing i've found in all this and
rich eisen talked to me a little bit
about it earlier
is that no one expected mac jones to be
a top five pick
until until kyle shanahan moved to this
spot and all of a sudden now
it's almost like he is a king maker
in this and is there's a lot of power in
this and we've talked about it before in
the past when
when somebody falls in love with
somebody it doesn't matter it only takes
one
and it may be kyle shanahan and john
lynch who just have fallen in love with
mack jones for what they can do
no no no doubt it could be just one now
i'll say this too right and i mean rich
rich is right that is the the the
thought that was out there
but i'd also like to say that thought
was out there
from people who don't make the decisions
in football
right you know when this trade was made
and everything
most of the nfl was just getting done
with draft stuff
so that's when you need to start paying
attention to what's being said and
things like that
you know before that it's a lot of hey
tv
scouts and you know hosts of radio shows
and
and highlight shows making proclamations
about where people should be picked in
the draft
so that was where that's where i'd fight
back against that and
you know i i have knowledge of things
that went on in the nfl after that i
i i know for a pretty good fact the
49ers traded up
because they knew teams were looking to
trade up to draft mac jones
and i think the first thing they knew
was they felt that the carolina panthers
were
hot on mac jones they coached them at
the senior bowl
and i don't think it's some coincidence
that you know
the you know the 49ers make the move and
do everything like that and not long
after
you see the panthers go okay we're going
to trade for sam darnold i think they
kind of told you right there they had
their eye on mac jones
and the other team that i think a lot of
people in the nfl world
thought would make a play for mack jones
is of course the obvious one that
everyone pins to him
which is the new england patriots so i
think there was a lot of thoughts by
people in the know
and i think that calls were made by the
patriots and the panthers to move up and
that's why
i think shanahan and the 49ers got wind
of that and that's why they made the
aggressive
move to get up to number three to make
sure they could have the pick of the
litter
uh and really know who and pick the guy
they want you know and take fate into
their own hands
we're talking with chris sims nbc sports
nfl analyst
uh you can check him out on the twitter
csims
uh when you get a chance um
what what do you see uh sorry c sims qb
on the twitter box it's not that big
i'm rightly fill it in for rich eisen
okay
what happens now if you remember when
donovan mcnabb was drafted second
overall and the philly fans went
absolutely berserk that that was not the
pick they wanted
what happens when the san francisco
49ers fans
uh hear that pick announced tonight and
the reaction
isn't overly great like it will be when
the jets take zach wilson who
if you would ask him a year ago who zach
wilson was or that he'll be the
quarterback next year they would have
been up in arms well you know i
it to me i mean they're going to have to
make sure they pub
pub this the right way yeah there's
going to be a negative reaction
you know with with some of these guys in
the draft hey the most
novice of football fans who just turns
on the tv
you know you could see more you know
unbelievable
ah draw dropping type of stuff from some
of the other quarterbacks so
that's where i think you know it's being
lost in translation as far as
the public's love for mac jones i mean
listen you don't need to be a genius to
see
zach wilson's workout and go that look
different those balls look like they fly
off of his hands
like holy crap and then of course people
have seen justin fields play
and they see whoa a really powerful arm
and a guy that is a special runner
and you know trey lance you see some of
the highlights up there at north dakota
state and they're impressive
mac jones is more of a machine he
doesn't have that one trait that just
jumps out to you where you just go oh my
gosh that's unbelievable
but i think it's what it is is you got
to look at it more of like
he checks the box at a really high level
in all categories
so when you go through it that way and
you go
okay most accurate passer in the draft
um
okay best in the pocket in the draft
either him or zach wilson with their
ability to move and slide and make
throws that way okay there's mac jones
in that
all right the ability to you know read
and diagnose and go to the right place
with the ball
mac jones wins that conversation that's
as good as anybody i've studied ryan
since
since i've been on this side of the
business it's him or joe burrow
his arm is just as good as joe burrows
was last year
so what i'm basically saying is and then
you know i hear people say
oh you don't get to see him throw under
pressure and do those type of things
yeah okay there's not a ton of it but
also taking the discount when he when
there is pressure he's phenomenal at
avoiding it and moving
and making the appropriate throw the
other thing too
uh is that you know the pressure thing
sometimes
doesn't get there because he knows it's
coming and gets the ball out of his
head quickly you know so that people
lose that site the site of that fact
and what i'm basically saying is listen
you add up all those things and what you
get
is an elite quarterback and that's what
mac jones is and ryan that's where
i think the 49ers got to do their best
job to sell to their fan base and just
be like
we just drafted drew brees that would be
what i would be telling them we just
drafted drew brees
put that out there and see if we can't
get the fan base a little excited but
it's gonna take results on the field to
back off that's for sure
yeah the things about the pressure right
tom brady and peyton manning are
terrible
with pressure but guess what they get
rid of it before the pressure gets to
them or they check out of it and put
them in a position to do something
differently also
exactly the argument being made that he
had a you know
first round draft picks at wide receiver
around him a first round draft pick and
a running back offensive lineman i i
simply
come back and i go you know who was joe
burrow playing with a bunch of bombs
exactly you know this is about last year
right
had four first round receivers you know
that's my i'm with you ryan that that's
where it gets lost in translation too
much i get it
joe burrow was awesome awesome players
we we know that
you know desean watson wasn't with any
slouches at clemson either when he was
there
and neither were trevor lawrence
surrounded or just in fields by slouches
either
and then added to your point about the
alabama thing this is the last thing i
want to add about the mac jones
all you need to do is turn on film from
tua last year
and turn on film for matt jones and
it'll tell you by itself that alabama
thought mac jones was better than tua
the offense they run with matt jones is
more aggressive
and more dependent on the quarterback
being a better player
and that was one of the first things
that jumped out to me about it so
uh he from the start i always said
he is a better prospect than tua for me
there's no doubt about that
but it just hasn't been sold to the
public the same way it was tank fortuite
for trevor and it's hard to tell people
anything different once that kind of
gains momentum
it is it's hard it's hard when a
narrative has been spun um
right we're talking to chris sims nbc
sports nfl analyst
um you i released my mock draft
uh and your and yours uh ups up against
each other and
there was one sizeable difference in a
lot of people questioned and asked
why you felt justin fields falls so far
down the list you have him going 32nd
overall why did justin fields fall so
far uh
but regardless uh whoever gets them is
going to have a
a great quarterback for the future i do
believe
no i mean he's got a chance to be
special there's no doubt
but there's some issues and they're hard
issues to work on and i don't think all
teams in the nfl think they can be fixed
you know
he's got a little bit of a hitch in his
giddy up his throw
the way he lifts that elbow you know
anybody that's been paying attention to
his feet can get really weird at times
where he can push off a mound almost to
throw the ball
so he needs so much space and all of
those things
he's really needs to be polished as a
passer and really
work on fixing some of those flaws
within his mechanics
you know i didn't go into the mock drive
first off i didn't know my mock drive
was going to be like damn this is the
answer key and
it's written in stone i mean you know i
guess that's a positive thing about my
career but
i didn't go into it going okay i'm gonna
make justin feels the 30-second pick and
now let me fill in the rest of the draft
like i didn't do that
yeah i tried to realistically go through
it with hey
things i know about the draft and where
guys might go
and then when i got to situations where
like it was the denver broncos at nine
the denver broncos did what i always
thought they were gonna do
i thought they'd try to get stay with
drew locke and go with teddy bridgewater
maybe they still dropped a quarterback
tonight i don't know
but i kind of went oh all right so it's
vic sangio his butt's going to be on the
hot seat i could see them passing the
quarterback
and trying to get somebody that helps
them now i have
washington trading up to get trey lance
you know you get to the bears at 20.
you know i don't know i understand they
need a quarterback
but again here we are are they giving
matt
matt nagy and ryan pace the green light
when it sounds like their butts on the
hot seat to draft any quarterback and
trade their way any assets they want
and then what leave the next coaching
regime in the same spot they left matt
nagy where he gets to take over a team
of a quarterback that he doesn't like
and mitchell trubisky so then i went to
that i went oh i don't think that's
gonna happen
and i just kind of organically as i went
through it i know there's a good chance
that somebody would trade up into the
late 20s there if he was available
but i kind of just filled it out and
went with it and i went i got to the
32nd the bucks and i went man the bucks
don't have any needs
and if it got to this point i'm not sure
they might not trade out of the pick
because they might go we got a
quarterback this is the perfect
situation
for for fields and the last thing i'll
just say to everybody
like i i i'm humbled in a way that
people
took it so like it was the the trap
like the like the answer key but at the
same time
there's always a curveball in the draft
and that was my curveball
did that nobody thought lamar jackson
was going to be the 32nd pick
nobody thought aaron rodgers was going
to be pick 24.
there's stuff like this all the time so
i it kind of just organically worked it
out
worked that way and uh yeah i've taken a
lot of flack i'm the biggest justice
field hater in the world now
all right speaking of aaron rodgers uh
just you know today's rumor mill of
course gets
gets spun up uh his name has been
has been heard on the lips of some
people today in terms of
people inquiring what it would take to
maybe get an aaron rodgers on their
roster so far no
no biters out of green bay but what do
you think about his name continuously
uh being brought up as a possibility
somewhere else other than green bay
yeah right i think it's going to
continue i i do
i i i said on you know pro football talk
with floria the other day i go i just
i i'd almost bet anything to say right
this will be gr green
the last year with rogers in green bay i
you know
i think he's had it um and i don't think
they're gonna give him the long-term
security you know as far as years down
the road
to make him feel like he's the guy for
any more time than maybe one or two
years so i think
that's why you hear like green bay
talking about
you know we'll figure out a way to
negotiate a contract and do
do that kind of stuff i i'm gonna bet
you that roger's gonna say no thanks
i'll just leave the contract the way it
is and i think rogers will make a move
after the year
i really do but i think they're going to
continue to field these calls because i
think most of the nfl feels the same way
as what i'm saying that things are a
little dicey up there
and i think a lot of people think rogers
can make a move to get the hell out of
there
if not somewhere else in a uniform
definitely with a tie on
asking people uh jeopardy questions it
sounds like
chris sims nbc sports
nfl analyst uh hey brother man thanks so
much for joining us and being part of
the day enjoy
tonight in tonight's nfl draft you too
ryan you the man man be good good luck
with everything
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here